so
what are we talking about today
about my favorite problem
in geometry when i was a fifth grader
and it is etched in my memory
to the point of being able to recall it
at any time so we have three squares of
the same sizes next to each other the
size does not matter and
three
so what we will do is pick one of the
top corners let's say the top left
corner and connect it
to
the bottom right corners of each of
those three squares
next we will take this angle here at the
bottom let's call it alpha the next one
at the bottom let's call it oh how do
you write beta from that side
beta and and that's incorrect
this
is it upside down
and finally
gamma
all right so the question
is asking what is the sum of these three
angles so a simple enough problem the
interesting part of it is that it was
given to me as a fifth grader so i had
to attack it as a fifth grader in fifth
grade
we learned how to use a protractor so i
measure the first angle it's about 45
degrees and in fact then you can stop
and think about it but of course it has
to be 45 since the triangle we are
looking at is right
an isosceles this guy here
so that should not be a surprise you get
a 45 degree angle there and we go about
measuring the others
but there perhaps we
run a little bit out of luck
because the second angle
looks like it's pointing to 25 and a
little bit maybe 26 and the third angle
wow where is it going perhaps
20 so about
18. so when we add this up
could that be it
what do you think
it seems a bit arbitrary it doesn't have
tonight yeah and also there were all of
these mistakes in our measurement and
why would they be asking a fifth grader
how much this is and ending up with such
a random angle well if you
try to make another measurement perhaps
you will come up
with
91.3 and so you would say oh it's a
little bit obtuse but maybe it's a
little bit acute
so what would be a conjecture that
people
will leap to
if they believe this is a beautiful
problem
i i would guess that the correct answer
they would think the correct answer is
90. exactly 90
but how would we know really
is it 90
or some ugly angle nearby we cheat a
little bit we say okay that problem was
given to a fifth grader it has got to be
a nice answer
we will believe for a moment it's 90 and
this is what mathematicians call a
conjecture and then put all of our
effort into proving that it is 90.
and we are kind of a third of the way
to proving it because we know that one
of the angles for sure
is 45
so what should be left for the other two
angles in order to make 90
well obviously 45
so somehow we need to add up the other
two angles beta and gamma and prove that
they add up to 45.
another experiment which a
fifth grader might try and you can also
do at home is cut up the whole thing
with scissors
and
eliminate
some of the error that is coming from
the protractor when you are
rounding the degrees
okay
so let's try to put everything together
if we can
it does look like
this is a 90 degree let's check
yep
it does look like 90 degrees okay so now
we truly believe the statement
and we want to prove it well the
question is at what level of your
mathematical career or mathematical life
you are
because this problem has not only one
not only two but at least
54 solutions
54 solutions now kidding if we can do
all of them
no we will do the most brilliant one the
most simple one that a fifth grader
might be able to grasp so the idea of
our solution
at least the attempt when we cut with
scissors can be carried forward
mathematically
so we may want to move all three angles
into the same geometric location in our
picture so we need to find the best
geometric location where to move those
three angles well there is no base
geometric location until you know what
the solution is
so we might as well just try to move
them all the way in this corner next to
gamma because we already have a right
angle here
this guy we have gamma here and so the
other two angles alpha and beta must
somehow fit and here comes the brilliant
idea of this solution
as i said there is something missing in
this picture
what's missing is half of the picture
we will replicate these three squares up
and then we'll start seeing the truth
and now i think i'm going to start
labeling things so people can refer to
them later on
i'm just labeling all of the
important
points
i will choose point h
and connect it to two other points
d
and e
and i will say that no more
constructions will be done in this
solution we somehow have to make sense
of what this picture is telling us well
for starters we see three angles exactly
where we wanted them to be where this 90
degree angle was we have our original
gamma and then two more could those two
angles be indeed alpha and beta well
you can kind of guess that this angle
is bigger than the next one
by the way it looks so perhaps that will
be the 45 alpha because alpha was bigger
than beta
could this be 45
and let's try as detectives figure out
where it could come from this picture
it is involved in this
large triangle
did we see a similar situation earlier
in the problem
certainly
right here where we saw our original
alpha
and where we decided that alpha is 45
degrees
because this was a e e
a b e was a right isosceles triangle
do we have a right isosceles triangle
here
we might could e h
be equal to hd
these are the two extra segments that we
drawn top
the answer is yes
because
these two segments are
hypotenuses
hypotenuse or hypotenuses
i know what you mean
so eh and hd the two segments which we
drew
are the hypothesis of two right
triangles
two that we also draw on top so i'm
going to mark them in blue
so these two sides are hypotheses of two
right triangles
e f h
and h i d the ones which i drew in blue
now they're right because they have a
right angle here coming from top
but they are also exactly the same size
and shape this right triangle has one
leg two and the other leg one
and this one also has a leg of two and
leg of one which means
that their third size the two
hypotenuses must be the same
so indeed eh is equal to hd
and we are on our way to show that this
big green triangle in the middle is
right isosceles it's already isosceles
question is why is this guy right okay
but
what else is around this angle
there is this guy here
this angle and this other one
what do they add up to
and the answer is also very simple
one of those angles we already know
i claim that this angle is our angle
beta
because
there is a third triangle which is
precisely the same shape and size as
those
it is right here
again a right triangle
with legs one and two and so therefore
this angle beta must be equal to this
angle beta and guess what it must be
equal to this angle beta they all share
exactly the same
angle so accidentally
we have shown that we have moved angle
beta to where we wanted it gamma is
there
and if that is really 45 we will be done
and again backtracking we wanted to show
that this big triangle was right
isosceles
we already know that this angle here is
beta
what is this guy
well this guy
this second angle
participates in a right triangle where
the other acute angle is beta what could
this guy be
we know that the angles in a triangle
add up to a hundred and eighty
this guy is ninety therefore these two
must add up to ninety
simple arithmetic shows
that this angle here must be 90 minus
beta
90 minus beta something and beta must
overall
give you 180.
what is the remaining angle here this
curly one if you start adding up let's
do it
beta
plus 90 minus beta
plus something must be 180.
so beta goes away
and that something turns out to be our
90 degrees
you've done it that's right
so our angle alpha is indeed moved here
along with beta
and we can conclude
that the three angles add up to 90
degrees
and this is an amazing construction
which uses only squares
isosceles triangles
in congruent right triangles with legs
one and two
and that is indeed a brilliant approach
which mathematicians take to solve
problems
they complete it to what's missing there
and then the problem becomes greenland
so enough gasoline in greenland to add
up to two mathematicians may find that
question a bit too hard